speeding distracted driving and running
red lights they are Trends a new study
has linked to thousands of car crashes
right here in Nevada and many of those
crashes ended in death
Ian Matthew joins
join Jones the location of a
multi-vehicle fatal Collision from last
week with what this report reveals
yeah Kirsten Brian just on Tuesday alone
last week we had four fatal car
collisions throughout the valley the one
here sent six people to the hospital
another person dead you can still see
the markings on the floor of where the
car jumped over the median a new study
is evaluating thousands of Nevada
crashes like this from over a decade
identifying risk-taking behaviors that's
taking people's lives
[Music]
this is a Statewide issue drama Critical
Care surgeon and assistant Dean for
research at unlv's Krikorian School of
Medicine Dr Deborah cools has attended
to hundreds of car crash victims
fighting for their lives and they are
very very badly injured The first-hand
Experience leading to a deep dive of
crashes across the state
in 2020 over a hundred and fifteen
thousand people nationally were injured
and over 900 killed by vehicles running
red lights in Nevada it represented 32
percent of all fatalities pedestrians
bicyclists and vehicle passengers were
killed over half the time with the
driver most commonly young men with
prior crashes and alcohol impaired
convictions over 50 percent of all
traffic citations involved speeding 34
percent of those for going over the
state's maximum speed limit the majority
of these behaviors are really exhibited
Off the Strip they're exhibited on our
local streets on our highways as for
traffic citations five percent of those
in Nevada were for distracted driving
looking at a cell phone or inattentively
driving that's taken the lives of too
many and for those who survive some of
them will never be able to work again
we'll never be able to go home again or
if they do they'll have significant
impairments
now she adds over half of all these
crashes happened here in Clark County
Jules lawmakers will use this data to
further penalize this kind of driving
now traffic Conformity cameras are what
she believes would help keep these
offenders accountable though at the
moment Nevada law prevents those cameras
from being here in the state reporting
live near Di and Jones Ryan Matthey a
news now